if there's one person other than joe
biden himself who's most responsible for
the woes of today's democrat party it's
this woman
randy weingarten president of the
american federation of teachers
now with a radical political ideology
and a huge budget to advance it
she has more influence on what happens
in our schools than any superintendent
or school board member
aft's massive donor base has translated
into major political clout now whether
we're talking
woke curricula coveted mandate school
closures educational choice
weingarten's views carry enormous weight
among democrats
the three members of the san francisco
school board who were just recalled on
tuesday night cared more about
satisfying weingarten and the teachers
unions than the parents whose children
they serve
now whenever overpaid educrats work
overtime to protect teachers and advance
the leftist political agenda the aft is
super happy
what's best for children is never their
primary consideration no matter how much
weingarten tried to argue to the
contrary
we tried to actually reopen schools more
quickly than almost anybody else we know
in-person learning is really important i
sat on the cuomo commission we put out a
report out in august in april of 2020
about the steps to reopen schools and
how safety was a vehicle to reopen
schools
but the states that took her advice
are battling lockdowns and mask mandates
to this day
meanwhile states like florida texas
south dakota they figured out early on
that the classroom was among the safest
places for children we all knew that
in-person english class wasn't any more
of a super spreader than in-person
shopping at costco
but randy she didn't care
for her covid was an opportunity and she
tries to squeeze out as many concessions
from you taxpayers as possible
we need the money for ppe we need the
money for
extra teachers we need the money for
extra cleaning and extra buses
pure extortion of course even after
democrats in washington appropriated
billions to reopen schools
the unions just made more excuses to
lock kids out of class
so the goal pose kept shifting
we'll reopen schools if you give us n95s
and contact tracing
we'll only get back to work when all
children are vaccinated if you redo the
entire hvac system in school
it was all ridiculous
it was never enough we know that and
even biden was after he was elected and
the democrats earmarked billions for
schools that wasn't enough
and randy was always on hand to take the
side of teachers who didn't want to
teach
the fear isn't gone
you see it and who is back in school and
who isn't
some school staff
need accommodations
and who can forget how nasty and sloppy
randy's acolytes became during covent
sitting at home and their athleisure
wear they felt very entitled and
superior to the parents asking very
inconvenient questions
if you're going to call me out i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up
sorry that's just me they want to pick
on us because they want their
babysitters back
gosh i forgot about that one now these
clowns
say what weingarten thinks but isn't
stupid enough to say out loud
on second thought she did let slip what
she really thought of parents by
enthusiastically tweeting out a
washington post titled
parents claim they have the right to
shape their kid's school curriculum
they don't
well neither she nor her activist
members think parents have any right to
offer input let alone make demands about
what they're teaching and how they're
teaching it
instead they act like they're the bosses
of the taxpayers who fund their salaries
and the democrat politicians
they fund well they just sing the same
tune
i met with the teachers unions they want
to go back to school they need some
guidance my union has been trying to
reopen school since last april we know
how important in-school learning is
now they flex their muscle in the biden
administration to keep schools closed as
long as possible perverting the cdc's
guidance on reopening
they pushed for rewriting key lines in
the agency's final draft and when they
got caught by the new york post well
weingarten just brazenly brushed it off
the post saying those two suggestions
that you offered at least your
organization offered make it nearly
verbatim in the final draft do you call
that normal as far as the ability to do
that they asked us for language and we
gave them language when they asked us
for it so there's nothing nefarious
about doing these kind this kind of work
now nothing nefarious just your
government acting like the pawn of the
teachers unions move along folks don't
pay attention to that
no but of course they could always count
on grandma mimi to put a positive spin
on the union's blatant corruption no
matter how many kids were hurt
my whole mission in congress is about
the children for the children
as you heard me say
you're in the arena you have to be
prepared to take a punch
you have to be prepared to throw a punch
for the children
for the children
that's echoing in my mind the democrats
cared so much about the children that
they joined themselves at the hip with
the most anti-child personality out
there
what they did to our kids has been
nothing short of devastating lost
learning anxiety lack of exercise weight
gain depression drug use lost
socialization that's just a start
all of that was brought on by the
lockdowns that weingarten strenuously
advocated
did parents ever get an apology from her
of course not because she doesn't think
she did anything wrong and even as mass
mandates are being dropped everywhere
weingarten is still refusing to budge
what's the argument against taking off
masks in schools let me just say this
i am in favor of an off-ramp on mass
right the real issue becomes
are is the is
is the spread
low enough
so that there's no dissemination or
transmission in schools
you heard her the mass stay on until
there's no transmission in schools ever
that means zero covered
that means mass forever
this woman is a menace
she couldn't get elected to pick up dog
poop in san francisco today now during
his campaign biden proudly promised to
be a puppet for the teachers union and
that's one promise he has kept but if
biden continues to do that woman's
bidding he may find himself struggling
even in liberal states a new uc berkeley
poll found that biden only has like 47
over 48 approval disapproval
in california and get this kamala harris
she's had 38 approval in california
that's her home state need i remind you
so things are really dire for the
democrats here
the guy who's really in charge though
you know who he is his name's ron clayne
biden's chief of staff
he headed up to capitol hill today to
reassure democrats that the white house
will seek bipartisan solutions going
forward
well those are nice words but we've
heard them before
the democrats need something all right
they need a clean break with the human
wrecking ball who smashed our schools to
smithereens these past two years
but i'm not holding my breath
but now
is the time for conservatives to make
inroads in these states states like
california new york illinois where
parents of all political stripes are
they're waking up
kevin robinson of san francisco told the
la la times that
he found himself nodding along an
agreement with staunch republicans
people on fox right wing news groups
we were the biggest district in the
country that was the last to open up
schools we became a laughingstock of the
world
how could this happen he said
he's just one of many democrats who
suddenly found themselves voting with
republicans against school board members
who just wouldn't listen
so with all of this
i just refuse to believe that states
like new york and california the home
states of bill buckley and ronald reagan
are forever lost to the left
these are our fellow americans
and we should do everything possible to
help them
the democrats policies have led to high
crime and high prices and they've
devastated our public schools
but because of our commitment to keeping
the schools open and parents in control
look what we did we took back virginia
we nearly unseated phil murphy in new
jersey
and we've reclaimed school board seats
all across the country this is only the
beginning
so if biden and harris aren't popular in
california and they're not
then the democrats are vulnerable
everywhere
the longer the democrats dance to randy
weingarten's tune the stronger our
populist movement will become
and only by beating them in 2022 and
2024 can we finally put this nonsense
behind us and return our kids back to
schools real schools that really teach
that are not only open but responsive to
the will of the parents
and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else